the British Broadcasting Corporation has
been embroiled in yet another giant
racism Scandal if you miss the story
Radio 5 live presenter nihal arthon
nyaki revealed that his terrible
experiences at the national broadcaster
left him struggling with his mental
health the situation is really affecting
him he explained so what happened
exactly did a group of colleagues show
up to the BBC canteen holding aoft
pictures of Tommy Robinson chanting
England till I die was Mr aan Yaki told
to go back where he came from no the
allegations made by Mr ayaki are far
more serious even than that in a
shocking statement to the journalism
diversity fund conference at BBC Media
city he explained that his mental health
problems are down to the overwhelmingly
white working environment he is forced
to endure on a daily basis it's really
affecting me that I walk in and all I
see is white people he added ayaki
further explained that when he raised
the problem his colleagues response was
often to say that they were not being
racist can you believe it when Mr ayaki
bravely confronted his fellow employees
for the offense of being white they
brazenly denied that their skin color
was a racist hate crime outrageous he
further added that the hardest thing is
to walk into a room look around and
nobody looks like you Mr aan yaki's
parents are from Sri Lanka now I've
never been to Sri Lanka but I am willing
to bet the equivalent of his excessive
£150,000 the year salary that very few
people in Sri Lanka would Place having
to walk into a room where nobody looks
like you at the top of their list of the
hardest things to do what is more were I
to move to Sri Lanka I would be rather
disappointed if the son my wife and I
raised there grew up complaining about
the Sri Lankan National broadcast that
being staffed primarily by brown people
were this to occur I imagine I would
feel the pressing need to remind him of
the tremendous opportunities he enjoyed
thanks to the fact that his parents were
allowed to to make their home in Sri
Lanka I would caution him in the
strongest terms against adopting the
pentious and racist idea that people
should be judged on the color of their
skins rather than the content of the
character I might even suggest that if
he's so uncomfortable with being
surrounded by brown people that it is
affecting his mental health and perhaps
Sri Lanka is the wrong country for him
and he may wish to consider following my
example by moving to a country that is
more to his liking I would also not be
surprised if his racist remarks were bad
received by the public and resulted in
some sort of formal statement from his
employer the national broadcaster
distancing itself from his comments
given that it is funded after all by a
lot of ordinary Sri Lankans of the skin
color that makes him so uncomfortable
and in a San world all of this would
also happen in Britain to nihal arthan
Yaki but it weren't of course because we
don't live in the same world we live in
a world where the response to his
overtly racist comments has been for the
BBC to issue a statement that the
organized ation is committed to tackling
the lack of diversity in its newsrooms
in other words the BBC agrees with Mr
Aran aaki that there are too many white
people working there in fairness this
isn't actually news because the BBC has
openly discriminated against white
people for some time by Banning them
from applying for certain opportunities
because it is the right thing to do I
take no pleasure in chronicling the now
inevitable and entirely self-inflicted
death of what was once an organization
that was truly the Envy of the world and
the the gold standard for Public
Broadcasting my grandfather freed his
mind while living under Soviet
totalitarianism by listening to BBC
World Service a neutral and
journalistically excellent public
service broadcaster is a wonderful thing
to have and there are still many great
journalist at the BBC but the machine
itself has become corrupted as a result
of flooding the organization with woke
graduates and a never ending obsession
with diversity over Merit I wish it
could be saved from its own Suicidal
Tendencies but but alas there is no
Samaritans helpline for institutions
that are intent on destroying themselves
a couple of quick things before you go
first of all if you enjoy these videos
you should know that they're available
much earlier on my substack head on over
there now and subscribe secondly let me
take a minute to recommend a longevity
supplement by Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David CLA have recently made
some fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is cell beinging cell beinging
helps combat aging by increasing
something called NAD Plus in your body
now NAD is arguably the most important
molecule in your body High NAD levels
improve your metabolism repair damage
DNA and increase energy production in
your brain immune system and your
muscles but as you grow old your body's
NAD levels go down and you can't take
NAD as a supplement because it's too big
for yourselves to absorb that's why
Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
this video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join me you can get
15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.o and use our code trigger to save 15%
off your order and if you enjoyed this
video then make sure to watch this other
one where I explain why the world makes
less and less sense every
year